the name ice cube yeah uh that came
about because of your brother yeah your
real name o'shea yeah uh
which is kind of a cool name right yeah
o'shea right i'm not irish but it's kind
of cool why'd your parents name you
o'shea did you ever ask them that yeah
uh my mother liked the name uh oj oj
yeah she he was big at usc right doing
his thing and she kind of liked the way
that sounded yeah but so
i guess she came up with o'shea she was
the original rhymer she was yeah
that's why i got it and uh you had an
older brother yeah
i guess your older brother had girls
calling him all the time and you would
get on the phone yeah and start to hit
on these girls that were calling him
yeah i was going through puberty and so
how does how does the name ice cube come
out of that scenario well you know when
he found out cause the girls kept
telling him yo who's your little brother
keep getting on the phone
trying to knock me down
you know he kind of cornered me one day
he was like dude you know stop trying to
talk to my women man you know i'm like
well be home you know he's like and we
saw this case where this kid
they left a refrigerator on the on the
on the curb and the kid
got into the refrigerator and suffocated
oh dear it was pretty terrible and he
was like you know what
i'm gonna stuff your ass in that freezer
like that kid and when they pull you out
you're gonna be ice cube yeah and that
was it and i just was like so you know
do it and then it just i just took it on
as a badge of honor and when i walked
outside i'm like don't call me or shay
no more it's ice cubes no no now when
you decide to change your name to ice
cube yeah you got to go around and
announce to the neighborhood my name is
now ice cube do some guys say [ __ ] you
yeah i'm not calling you ice cube that's
ridiculous and i'm like i'm just not
gonna answer you really yeah if you
don't call me cube i'm not gonna answer
you that's beautiful because you're
calling me my
government name and [ __ ] i'm like nah
man there were two people on this show
who tried to change the name robin tried
to change her name to robin ophelia and
fred tried to change his name to eric
yes
and fred tried to change his name to
eric and it never took actually changed
his name legally but nobody would do it
do you make your parents do you say to
your mother i would prefer you call me
cube at this point no no they can call
me i'm saying you know my parents can
call me anything they want to but
everybody else
you know unless you got a check
call me cute
you